click on the graph below to draw a right
triangle with right angle at x equals 8
y equals 6 and hypotenuse extending from
0 comma 14 to negative 10 comma negative
12 well it looks like they've given us
the three vertices of the triangle so we
could just plot them so let's just it
says click to add vertices so let's do
that we have one at eight comma 6 x
equals 8 y is equal to 6 then we have 1
at 0 comma 14 so x equals 0 Y is equal
to 14 and it drew the line there and
then we go from negative and then we go
from that point 2 negative 10 comma
negative 12 negative 10 I'm sorry X is
negative 10 X is negative 10 y is
negative 12 so we go to that point right
over there and then we can just connect
everything back by going to our original
point and there we haven't even drew the
nice right angle right over there there
we have it we have our right triangle
we'd literally just have to plot the
points in order actually any order would
have worked because there's only three
points here so yeah that was it